>>> BREAKING NEWS.
MORE THAN 30 SUBPOENAS IN RECENT
DAYS TO PEOPLE IN DONALD TRUMP'S
ORBIT AS PART OF ITS JANUARY 6th
PROBE.
IT'S A MAJOR DEVELOPMENT IN THE
INVESTIGATION AMID THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS WHICH OF COURSE ARE
NOW ONLY TWO MONTHS AWAY.
SOURCES TELL CNN THAT THOSE WHO
WERE SERVED THOSE SUBPOENAS ARE
AMONG TRUMP'S TOP ADVISERS AND
ALLIES.
THAT INCLUDES BRIAN JACK,
TRUMP'S FORMER WHITE HOUSE
POLITICAL DIRECTOR AND HIS
FORMER DEPUTY CHIEF OF STAFF DAN
SCAVINO AND BILL STEPIEN.
FINDING OUT ABOUT MORE THAN 30
SUBPOENAS IN JUST A FEW DAYS,
THAT'S A LOT.
WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT THEM?
>> WELL, THAT'S RIGHT, ERIN.
I THINK THIS SIGNIFIES REALLY AN
INTENSIFICATION OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT INVESTIGATION, ALL OF
THESE SUBPOENAS COMING IN JUST
IN THE PAST WEEK OR SO.
IT APPEARS TO BE AN EFFORT BY
PROSECUTORS TO GET AHEAD OF THE
QUIET PERIOD, A 60-DAY PERIOD IN
WHICH THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS
LOOKING AT ANYTHING THAT COULD
INFLUENCE THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
THE SCOPE OF THESE SUBPOENAS
WE'VE SEEN AT LEAST A COUPLE OF
THEM APPEAR TO HAVE A RANGE OF
ISSUES THAT THEY ARE GOING
AFTER, INCLUDING SOME OF THE
FUNDRAISING FOR THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S SAVE AMERICA PACT.
SOME OF THE EFFORTS BEHIND THE
FAKE ELECTOR SCHEME, AS WELL AS
SOME OF THE EFFORTS THAT THEY
WERE MAKING TO TRY TO FIND FRAUD
AND WHETHER THERE WAS ANY
INDICATION THAT THEY HAD PROOF
OF ANY OF THAT FRAUD.
AGAIN, THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
PROSECUTORS SEEM TO BE TRYING TO
CONNECT THE DOTS BEHIND SOME OF
THE EFFORTS TO OVERTURN THE
ELECTION RESULTS.
YOU MENTIONED SOME OF THE NAMES.
BILL STEPIEN WHO WAS A FORMER
CAMPAIGN MANAGER FOR THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
SEAN DOLLMAN, CFO OF THE 2020
CAMPAIGN.
AND OF COURSE DAN SCAVINO, WHO
WAS THE DEPUTY CHIEF OF STAFF.
HE WAS OF COURSE THE GUY WHO WAS
WRITING A LOT OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S TWEETS.
SO A LOT OF VERY IMPORTANT
FIGURES VERY CLOSE TO THE FORMER
PRESIDENT GETTING THESE
SUBPOENAS.
>> AND THIS IS IN THE CONTEXT OF
THE PROBE INTO THE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS FOUND AT MAR-A-LAGO.
SO TODAY TRUMP'S LEGAL TEAM
OPPOSED BOTH THE DOJ'S BID TO
RESUME ITS REVIEW OF CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS AND ITS PICKS FOR A
SPECIAL MASTER.
THAT'S WHAT WE HAD HEARD TODAY
AS THIS DAY HAS GONE ON.
WHY ARE THEY OBJECTING?
>> THEY SAY THEY'RE NOT REALLY
GOING TO EXPLAIN WHY THEY'RE
OBJECTING, ERIN, IN THIS COURT
FILING.
THEY JUST SAY THAT THEY HAVE
OBJECTIONS TO THEM, AND THEY
WANT THE JUDGE ESSENTIALLY TO
FORCE THEM TO EXPLAIN IT.
I'LL READ YOU JUST A PART OF
WHAT THEY SAID.
PLAINTIFF OBJECTS TO THE
PROPOSED NOMINEES OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
PLAINTIFF BELIEVES THAT THERE
ARE SPECIFIC REASONS WHY THOSE
NOMINEES ARE NOT PREFERRED FOR
SERVICE AS SPECIAL MASTER IN
THIS CASE.
PLAINTIFF ALSO SUBMITS THAT IT
IS MORE RESPECTFUL TO THE
CANDIDATES FROM EITHER PARTY TO
WITHHOLD THE BASIS FOR
OPPOSITION FROM A PUBLIC AND
LIKELY WOULD BE CIRCULATED
WIDELY CIRCULATED PLEADING.
SO, ESSENTIALLY, THEY'RE ASKING
THE JUDGE FOR PERMISSION TO
EXPLAIN TO HER BEHIND THE SCENES
WHY THEY DON'T WANT THESE TWO
SPECIFIC FORMER JUDGES THAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS
RECOMMENDED.
>> EVAN, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
REPORTING FROM WASHINGTON.
I WANT TO GO NOW TO THE FORMER
CHIEF OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT'S COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
SECTION AND WHO INVESTIGATED
HILLARY CLINTON'S HANDLING OF
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
DAVID, YOU KNOW ABOUT THIS FROM
EVERY ANGLE.
LET'S START WITH THE SUBPOENAS.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT ISSUES
MORE THAN 30 SUBPOENAS WITHIN A
MATTER OF DAYS FOR ITS PROBE
INTO JANUARY 6th.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE FACT
THAT THERE ARE MORE THAN 30
SUBPOENAS HAPPENING IN A MATTER
OF DAYS AT THIS SPECIFIC TIME?
>> I MEAN, IT TELLS ME THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND THE FBI
ARE ALL IN, IN PURSUING THAT
PROSECUTORS AND AGENTS REFER TO
AS LOGICAL INVESTIGATIVE STEPS.
THEY ARE BUILDING WHAT THEY'VE
LEARNED FROM OTHER WITNESSES
FROM OTHER DOCUMENTS, FROM OTHER
SUBPOENAS, FROM OTHER SEARCH
WARRANTS.
THIS IS THE WAY CLASSIC
INVESTIGATIONS ARE CONDUCTED,
MOVING UP THE CHAIN SO TO SPEAK.
THEY'RE NOW ENCOMPASSING
INDIVIDUALS CLOSER AND CLOSER TO
THE PRESIDENT TO LEARN MORE AND
MORE ABOUT WHAT THE PRESIDENT
KNEW AND WHEN HE KNEW IT WITH
RESPECT POTENTIALLY TO EFFORTS
TO ENGAGE IN WIRE FRAUD,
DEFRAUDING -- DONATING PUBLIC,
IF YOU WILL, WITH RESPECT TO THE
CAMPAIGN ORGANIZATION, OR
EFFORTS TO DEFRAUD THE UNITED
STATES WITH RESPECT TO FOMENTING
A FALSE SLATE OF ELECTORS TO
SUBBORN A FREE AND FAIR
ELECTION.
>> THE TRUMP LEGAL TEAM TODAY
OPPOSED THE DOJ'S BID TO REFUSE
LOOKING AT THE DOCUMENTS FOUND
AT MAR-A-LAGO.
WHATEVER YOU WANT TO SAY ABOUT
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE, IT WOULDN'T
APPLY TO CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS,
THEY WANT TO GO AHEAD THEREFORE
WITH THEIR REVIEW BECAUSE THEY
SAY TIME IS OF THE ESSENCE, THAT
IT'S URGENT FOR NATIONAL
SECURITY REASONS.
THE TRUMP TEAM ARGUMENT AS TO
WHY THEY SHOULD NOT DO THAT.
THEY SAY, IN PART, IN WHAT AT
ITS CORE IS A DOCUMENT STORAGE
DISPUTE THAT HAS SPIRALLED OUT
OF CONTROL, THE GOVERNMENT
WRONGFULLY SEEKS TO CRIMINALIZE
THE POSSESSION BY THE 45th
PRESIDENT OF HIS OWN
PRESIDENTIAL AND PERSONAL
RECORDS.
I DO WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT THIS
IS NOT A DOCUMENT STORAGE
DISPUTE.
THEY HAD MONTHS TO TURN OVER
DOCUMENTS THAT WERE REQUESTED.
THE TRUMP LAWYER EVEN SIGNED A
LETTER THAT ALL THE REQUESTED
DOCUMENTS HAD BEEN RETURNED WHEN
THEY HAD NOT BEEN RETURNED.
SO, IT'S NOT A DOCUMENT STORAGE
DISPUTE.
BUT DO YOU HAVE ANY FEAR THAT
THE JUDGE WILL BUY THIS?
>> UM, YES, I HAVE FEAR THAT THE
JUDGE WILL BUY IT.
IT'S MY HOPE THAT THE JUDGE WILL
TAKE THE OFF RAMP THAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS OFFERED
HER.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT COULD'VE
TAKEN A SLEDGE HAMMER TO THIS
JUDGE'S PRIOR RULING AND
OBLITERATED ALL THE GROUNDS SHE
SIGNED FOR IMPOSING THE
RESTRICTIONS SHE DID ON THE
GOVERNMENT'S INVESTIGATION.
INSTEAD, THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
SHREWDLY TOOK A SCALPEL TO THAT
ORDER AND FOCUSED ON THAT NARROW
SUBSET OF MATERIALS 100
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS, CLASSIFIED
AS HIGH AS TOP SECRET CODE WORD,
AND ASKED THE JUDGE FOR A STAY
OF THAT PORTION OF THE ORDER.
THE POSITION THE FORMER
PRESIDENT IS TAKING IS DEPLETELY
UNTETHERED TO LAW OR CUSTOM AND
PRACTICE.
HE HAS NO RIGHT OR POSSESSORY
INTEREST TO CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS.
NOR SHOULD A PRIVATE CITIZEN
WHO'S NOW A SPECIAL MASTER BE
INTERFERING IN AN ONGOING
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION, ONE THAT
HAS NATURAL SECURITY
IMPLICATIONS.
>> AND THERE'S ALSO IN THE
FOOTNOTE, CLASSIFIED OR
DECLASSIFIED THE DOCUMENTS
REMAIN EITHER PRESIDENTIAL
RECORDS OR PERSONAL RECORDS
UNDER THE PRA.
THEY KEEP MAKING THIS ARGUMENT.
I HAVEN'T FOUND ANY LEGAL EXPERT
THAT WOULD SAY THAT A CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENT IS PART OF THE
PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS.
IS THERE ANY WAY THEY COULD MAKE
SUCH AN ARGUMENT?
>> NO.
FIRST OF ALL, THEY FAILED TO
SIGN A PROVISION OF THE
PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS ACT THAT
SAYS THAT PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS
ARE THE SOLE POSSESSORY INTEREST
OF THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH, WHICH
DID NOT INCLUDE PRESIDENT TRUMP
AFTER HE LEFT OFFICE.
AND, SECONDLY, CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS ARE GOVERNED BY
EXECUTIVE ORDER BY
LONG-ESTABLISHED SUPREME COURT
PRECEDENT THAT THE SOLE
DISCRETION FOR DETERMINING WHAT
IS CLASSIFIED AND HOW THOSE
DOCUMENTS SHOULD BE HANDLED.
SO, THEY ARE TRYING TO SHIFT AND
DEFLECT FOCUS FROM WHAT IS, AT
ITS ROOT, VERY PROBLEMATIC
BEHAVIOR THAT EXPOSES THIS
PRESIDENT TO CRIMINAL JEOPARDY.
>> I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU